alors ce soir on commence vos infos
insolites par un salon de thé pas comme
les autres et c'est le cas de le dire
incroyable j'ai quand même pas moi-même
j'ai eu du mal à croire quand j'ai vu ça
alors en fait il s'agit d'Arthur dolmer
et de Jean-Emmanuel Thomas qui était qui
travaillait comme cuisinier au Royal
Monceau à Paris qui était ami et qui en
ont eu un petit peu marre et qui ont
décidé de se lancer et ils ont vu que le
marché du CBD fonctionnait très bien ils
sont dit pourquoi pas en vendre et
pourquoi pas surtout faire un salon de
thé donc ce serait le thème principal
donc finalement à Versailles tout près
faire ça il y a de plus en plus exotique
c'est pas compliqué je vous avais parlé
du japonais à la street food daysuko
d'accord ils sont à 3 mètres on a le
Japon et on a le CBD juste à côté donc
c'est un salon de thé vous venez vous
pouvez vous faire selon vos goûts ils
ont été assez rares avec ou sans CBD des
infusions avec ou sans CBD des des
pâtisseries avec ou sans CBD le plutôt
avec je crois alors le CBD faut pas
avoir peur c'est juste interdit au moins
de 18 ans et
ils vendent bien sûr aussi tous les
produits qu'on peut consommer chez soi
donc soit en huile soit en fleur soit en
résine et ce qui est vraiment
sympathique c'est qu'Arthur de Lemaire
et j'emmène Thomas sont des êtres
absolument adorables qui vous explique
tout selon vos besoins parce que vous
savez comme moi que ces BD ça peut quand
même aider à combattre certaines
douleurs articulaires musculaires oui le
CBD quand même le préciser c'est un
dérivé du cannabis mais ce n'est pas de
la drogue voilà c'est légal c'est
interdit au moins de 18 ans en France et
du coup vous n'avez pas le côté addictif
et au floraison de la drogue c'est
vraiment apaisant et c'est ça peut être
aussi dans la cuisine enfin comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure et ça peut
aider à s'endormir enfin donc si vous
êtes un peu stressé vous faites votre
marché à Versailles après vous allez
faire une grande théière de CDD ça va
coulisser de faire une bonne sieste
voilà par exemple voilà un endroit
incroyablement sympathique insolite
insolite pour le mois oui à mon avis oui
ça marche très bien ils ont des clients
de 30 à 70 ans et plus voilà alors pour
votre deuxième information on reste à
peu près dans le même thème mais oui ce
qu'on passe maintenant à l'utilisation
par un chef d'un produit pharmaceutique
et est-ce que c'est bien ça c'est la
nigelle exactement
vous en avez déjà parlé dans le Sept à
Huit c'est à monsieur qui a travaillé
dans des grands groupes qui est
énormément voyagé au Moyen-Orient
notamment il s'appelle Olivier Olivier
Olivier Decazes voilà il s'est associé
avec une pharmacienne et il a eu envie
de de proposer cette ni gel cette épice
incroyable cette épice c'est pas
compliqué elle guérit de tout sauf de la
mort Mathilde c'est pas mal guérir de la
mort
mais guérir de beaucoup de choses et
cette nigelle il faut qu'elle soit très
bonne
qui fait des bouchées de rouleau
d'avocat farci aux tartare de thon
agrémenté assaisonné à l'huile de
nigelle voilà tout simplement il a
d'autres secrets qui vous révélera à
l'occasion voilà on espère on verra
c'est sûr c'est sûr alors on termine vos
informations insolites par une
avant-première une avant-première pour
changer parce qu'on adore le cinéma et
c'est une avant-première qui va avoir
lieu
un lundi le lundi 27 mars à 20h et où à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est un film qui s'appelle
Les trois mousquetaires deux points
d'Artagnan en fait c'est un diptyque
vous avez celui-ci qui va sortir et
après il y aura les trois mousquetaires
deux points midi bon on va rester sur
celui-là pour commencer et en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'Alexandre
Dumas père a écrit ce roman de cap et
d'épée à Saint-Germain-en-Laye voilà il
a été aussi commandant non pardon il a
dirigé le commandement de la garde
nationale de Saint-Germain-en-Laye ainsi
que son théâtre donc effectivement vu
qu'il y a qu'une seule avant première
dans les Yvelines évidemment il fallait
la faire à Saint-Germain-en-Laye voilà
alors ce film il est réalisé par un
metteur un réalisateur n'importe quoi
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle Martin
Bourbon d'accord
d'accord
on acteur vous avez Françoise civil qui
joue d'Artagnan Vincent Cassel qui joue
je ne sais plus enfin un autre des des
beaux casting en tout cas là
il y a la bande-annonce qui s'affiche en
même temps
Duris c'est Aramis je m'en souviens
parce que ça rime et puis au marma il
dit qu'il a dû prendre 10 kg le pauvre
pour avoir l'air plus lourd évidemment
c'est le but du jeu la vraie sortie
officielle c'est le 5 avril vous avez
Eva Green et c'est ce film a été écrit
par souvenez-vous Alexandre de la
Patelière et Matthieu Delaporte les
auteurs du prénom
donne envie d'aller le voir j'ai
l'impression qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié
de dire d'autre sur cette
j'espère et intérêt
bon bah c'est bon je crois que j'ai tout
dit j'ai sur mon billet des trucs mais
tant pis donc ce sera au cinéma le 27
mars
lundi 27 20h avec l'équipe du film un
super je crois qu'on a tout dit merci
Mathilde merci beaucoup Véronique pour
ces informations on vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine